hi a smile is here and if you have a  problem with those nasty blood stains  and boy do I have the product for you  introducing assassins cream just apply  to your blood stain and run then voila  good as new no more nasty stains that  make you stick out in the crowd just  apply and rub in for immediate  long-lasting effect don't believe it  just ask this satisfied customer I  highly recommend this product help me  shave my evening where you can get  assassins cream right now for twenty  dollars and seven cents order now we  will throw in the assassin's creed  brotherhood pack it's enough for the  whole crew that's four times the  assassins cream for the price of one  hold the number on your screen now  Oh